As we embark on the third month of living under COVID-19 lockdown, parents and their kids may be getting on each other's nerves. If you're a parent working from home, you might be battling with your children and or your spouse for computer access. As your youngsters are trying to finish their school year via remote learning, maybe you're feeling stressed that there will be no summer camp this year and certainly no big out-of-town vacation. And if you're an essential worker, the fear of getting infected or infecting your family members has to be a constant. burden. Are there any new tips or tricks for coping? What about sharing space with other families, which is catching on in some areas? Is this advisable? And how can you keep your family safe, even as your children are seeing news stories about some Americans demanding to be, quote, freed from sheltering in place or wearing masks? Welcome to Speaking of Psychology, the flagship
随着我们进入新冠疫情封锁生活的第三个月，父母和孩子可能都有些心烦意乱。如果您是一位居家办公的家长，您可能正在为争夺电脑使用权而与孩子或配偶发生冲突。当您的孩子试图通过远程学习完成学业时，您或许会因为今年没有夏令营，更没有长途旅行而感到压力重重。如果您是一名一线工作人员，那么担心自己被感染或传染给家人的恐惧一定是沉重的负担。有什么应对的新技巧或方法吗？与其他家庭共享空间（这在某些地区正变得流行）怎么样？这样做可取吗？当您的孩子看到新闻报道说一些美国人要求“从居家令中解放”或拒绝戴口罩时，您该如何保障家人的安全？欢迎收听《心理学谈话》，这是美国心理学会的旗舰播客。
podcast of the American Psychological Association. I'm Kim Mills. Our guest today, is Dr. Earl Turner, a licensed clinical psychologist and assistant professor of psychology at Pepperdine University. Dr. Turner teaches courses on clinical psychology and multicultural issues. He is also an authority on child psychology and is president of the Society for Child and Family Policy and and Practice, which is a division of the American Psychological Association. Thanks for joining us, Dr. Turner. Thank you for having me. Let's start by talking about the fatigue that families must be feeling after sheltering in place for more than two months. As you're out talking and writing about families in COVID-19, what are you hearing about new pressures that are building up in some households?
我是主持人金·米尔斯。我们今天的嘉宾是厄尔·特纳博士，他是佩珀代因大学的执业临床心理学家和心理学助理教授。特纳博士教授临床心理学和多元文化议题课程。他也是儿童心理学领域的权威，并担任美国心理学会下属的儿童与家庭政策与实践协会主席。感谢您参加我们的节目，特纳博士。谢谢您的邀请。让我们先谈谈家庭在居家隔离两个多月后必然会感受到的疲惫感。在您与新冠疫情下的家庭交流并撰写相关文章时，您听到了哪些在一些家庭中不断积聚的新压力？
Yeah, that's a great question. I think one of the challenges is that, you know, everybody obviously is sheltered in place, and so it makes it much more difficult for you to be able to find space to be alone. And so I think that is a unique challenge that we are not accustomed to, given the current situation. So I think trying to figure out ways to make space for each other to be able to get a break is something that a lot of families are really struggling right now. What advice do you have for parents who live in states or communities that are starting to open up? How can they protect themselves and their families, but also convince their kids that
是的，这是一个很好的问题。我认为挑战之一在于，每个人显然都处于居家隔离状态，这使得寻找独处空间变得更加困难。我认为这是我们在当前形势下不习惯面对的独特挑战。因此，我认为设法为彼此腾出空间以获得喘息机会，是许多家庭目前真正挣扎的事情。对于那些居住在开始解封的州或社区的父母，您有什么建议？他们该如何保护自己和家人，同时又能说服孩子相信……
practices such as sheltering in place, wearing masks in public and staying six feet apart are not necessarily over? Yeah, I think that's very important to make sure that you continue to talk with your kids about this is still uncertain times in that we don't know a lot about how this virus is being spread. Obviously, we don't have a vaccine of cure yet for it. And so I think talking with children about, you know, we have to try to expand our ability to get outside of the home, but in a safe manner. And so that includes making sure that we continue to maintain physical distancing. that we wear our mask, that we continue to wash our hands, that we use sanitizer and all of those things as a way to continue to protect us and also limit the possibility that we may get infected
诸如居家隔离、在公共场所佩戴口罩以及保持六英尺社交距离等做法并不一定已经结束？是的，我认为确保继续与孩子沟通这一点非常重要，因为现在仍是不确定的时期，我们对这种病毒的传播方式了解还不够多。显然，我们还没有针对它的疫苗或疗法。因此，我认为与孩子沟通时要强调，我们必须设法在安全的前提下扩大户外活动范围。这包括确保我们继续保持身体距离、佩戴口罩、勤洗手、使用消毒剂，所有这些都是为了继续保护我们自己，并限制我们可能感染病毒的可能性。
with the virus. Is there some way to communicate with kids about these things without getting them stressed? Yeah, that's a great question. I think, you know, obviously we don't know much about the virus and how it spreads. So I think it's important to make sure that you. continue to communicate to kids about how necessary it is to maintain physical distancing, even when you're out in public, and that you also continue to, you know, wear your face coverings and that you also continue to engage in hand washing to limit the possibility that you
有没有什么方法可以在不给孩子造成压力的情况下与他们沟通这些事情？是的，这是一个很好的问题。我认为，显然我们对病毒及其传播方式知之甚少。因此，我认为确保继续向孩子传达在公共场合保持身体距离的必要性非常重要，同时也要继续佩戴口罩，并坚持洗手，以限制您感染病毒的可能性。
may contract the virus. Some countries, such as Canada and New Zealand, have introduced something that they're calling the double bubble where two families joined together. This allows their kids to play face to face and maybe the parents divide teaching responsibilities and they all share meals and basically they're allowed to socialize more. Do you think this is a good idea? Are we ready for this? That's a hard question for me. I think on one level we know that personal connection and relationships are important and obviously doing that in person is much easier than virtual meetings. And so I think I understand the perspective of the benefits of that. I think my concerns, would be sort of knowing how the virus is spread and, you know, are those, both of those families,
一些国家，如加拿大和新西兰，引入了一种被称为“双重泡沫”的模式，即两个家庭联合起来。这允许他们的孩子面对面玩耍，父母或许可以分担教学责任，他们可以共享餐食，基本上他们被允许进行更多的社交活动。您认为这是一个好主意吗？我们准备好迎接这种模式了吗？对我来说这是一个难题。我认为一方面我们知道人际联系和关系很重要，显然面对面交流比虚拟会议容易得多。所以我理解这种模式带来的益处。但我担心的是，考虑到我们对病毒传播方式的了解，这两个家庭……
have they been, you know, tested what sort of possibilities of them getting contact with individuals who may have been infected and they don't know? And so I think, you know, that's a difficult conversation to be able to go along those guidelines, but not really understanding what impact it might have in terms of like potential exposure. So it may not be outweighed by the benefits of being able to socialize with more people? Right. I just, I just, I personally don't think that it's quite as safe to sort of move along those lines yet when we don't really know, because we know that people can be infected and not have symptoms. And so I would be concerned about that. The issues facing families where a parent is a first responder or a frontline worker are quite different from families.
他们是否都接受过检测？他们接触到可能已感染但自己却不知道的人的可能性有多大？因此，我认为在不真正了解潜在暴露风险的情况下，遵循这些准则进行交流是很困难的。所以，社交带来的好处可能无法抵消潜在的风险？对，我个人认为，在我们还不完全了解的情况下，现在就采取这种做法还不够安全，因为我们知道人们可能在感染后没有症状。所以我对此感到担忧。对于父母是急救人员或一线工作者的家庭，其面临的问题与父母是远程办公的家庭截然不同。
where parents are teleworkers. And I've read some news stories about some parents who are spraying themselves all over with disinfectant before they go back into their house or they're living in separate quarters. How can parents manage the anxiety of children who are witnessing this behavior? Yeah, I think, you know, for most kids, if you are really open with them about the reason behind engaging in these behaviors, that it reduces some of their anxiety. And so I think for some parents, particularly those that you mentioned, there may be essential workers and have to leave the home, is that it may be difficult to sort of describe your reasoning behind that, or you may decide not to sort of have a lengthy conversation with kids about why you're doing that. So I think to reduce their anxiety, it's helpful to talk about why you're doing this, what the plan is for when you do return home so that, you know, you don't have kids rushing to, maybe hug you when you walk in the door so that way you can have an opportunity to disinfect and,
我读到一些新闻报道说，有些父母在回家前会用消毒剂喷洒全身，或者住在单独的房间里。父母该如何管理那些目睹了这种行为的孩子的焦虑情绪？是的，我认为对于大多数孩子来说，如果您坦诚地告诉他们这些行为背后的原因，就能减轻他们的一些焦虑。因此，我认为对于一些父母，特别是您提到的那些必须离家工作的必要岗位人员，可能很难描述您这样做的理由，或者您可能决定不与孩子进行冗长的谈话。因此，我认为为了减轻他们的焦虑，谈论您为什么要这样做、回家后的计划是什么很有帮助，这样孩子们就不会在您进门时急着拥抱您，从而让您有机会进行消毒和更换衣物。
you know, change clothes and those types of things. So I think having a plan and creating some of that structure really is helpful to reduce some of the anxiety for kids. Children of all ages are picking up on the fact that many people are dying from this coronavirus. How can parents manage their kids' fears as they are exposed to this daily drumbeat of a death count? Yeah, I think, you know, for me, as someone who talks with parents often about kids witnessing things that could potentially be traumatic, is that you do want to limit the amount of exposure to watching these things in the media or if it's an adolescent, having some, you know, monitoring of their access to social media where they may be inadvertently exposed to some of this information, is that that may be one way to sort of help with that. The other way is really when if you are connected to someone who maybe dies from COVID-19 is that you sort of talk with kids about, you know, their emotions and feelings around that. Obviously, people experience grief differently.
因此，我认为制定计划并建立一些结构确实有助于减轻孩子的焦虑。所有年龄段的孩子都在关注许多人死于这种冠状病毒的事实。当孩子们每天暴露在死亡人数的报道中时，父母该如何管理他们的恐惧？是的，我认为作为经常与父母讨论孩子可能目睹创伤性事件的人，您确实需要限制他们通过媒体观看这些内容的频率。如果是青少年，则需要监控他们对社交媒体的访问，以免他们无意中接触到这些信息，这可能是一种缓解方式。另一种方式是，如果您认识的人死于新冠肺炎，您需要与孩子谈论他们对这件事的情绪和感受。显然，人们经历悲伤的方式各不相同。
And so for kids, it might be difficult to understand if they are having a emotional reaction to that loss. And so I think talking with them might be one way to at least explore and understand, you know, what emotions they may be having related to some of those situations. A moment ago you talked about the possibility that a family might have experienced a death and about talking to children about it. Is there a danger if you try to suppress that if you keep it a secret from a child that maybe, you know, grandma died? Yeah.
因此对于孩子来说，如果他们对这种失去有情绪反应，可能很难理解。所以我认为与他们交谈可能是探索和理解他们与这些情况相关的情绪的一种方式。刚才您谈到了家庭可能经历死亡以及与孩子谈论这件事的可能性。如果您试图压抑它，或者对孩子隐瞒奶奶去世的消息，会有危险吗？是的。
I mean, I think, you know, one of the big difficulties about grief is that families sometimes struggle about how much. much information should they give a child around, you know, a death of a loved one. And so I think it's helpful to talk about that grief, but also celebrate the life of that person. And I think that can be one way to make sure that they have a healthy grieving process. So I think it's important to have some conversations around it. A recently published study out of China found that children confined at home by the lockdown have elevated rates of depression and anxiety. which is raising concerns about the risk for American kids as the pandemic sweeps our nation. And I'm just wondering, what are the signs of depression and anxiety in children that parents should be looking for?
我的意思是，我认为悲伤的一大难点在于，家庭有时会纠结于应该告诉孩子多少关于亲人去世的信息。因此，我认为谈论悲伤是有帮助的，但同时也要纪念那个人的生平。我认为这可以确保他们拥有健康的哀悼过程。所以我认为围绕这件事进行一些对话很重要。最近中国发表的一项研究发现，因封锁而被限制在家中的儿童，其抑郁和焦虑率有所上升，这引起了人们对疫情席卷美国时美国儿童所面临风险的担忧。我想知道，父母应该注意孩子出现抑郁和焦虑的哪些迹象？
Yeah, that's a great question. Obviously, we will have to continue to collect some data on outcomes associated with children that may be isolated due to state-at-home orders during the pandemic. But I think in terms of the anxiety that if kids begin to become more clingy, so, you know, constantly wanting to be around parents and not sort of having them out of sight, that might be something that might be sort of a warning sign about additional concerns. Also, if they are having difficulties, you know, sleeping, whether that's falling asleep at night or maintaining their sleep throughout the night, that might be also an additional concern around anxiety because what, happens is that because they're worried, you know, their brain is constantly thinking about those things. And so it's hard to sort of turn that off. And so because of that, they may have challenges with sleeping. And then in terms of the depression aspect, I think children may begin to, you know, talk about things of death or dying or, you know, being hopeless about things never getting better.
是的，这是一个很好的问题。显然，我们将不得不继续收集与疫情期间因居家令而隔离的儿童相关的结果数据。但我认为，就焦虑而言，如果孩子开始变得更加粘人，即不断地想要待在父母身边，不让父母离开视线，这可能是一个需要警惕的额外担忧信号。此外，如果他们有睡眠困难，无论是晚上入睡困难还是整晚无法保持睡眠，这也可能是焦虑带来的额外担忧，因为他们担心的事情会让大脑不断思考，很难停下来。因此，他们可能会有睡眠挑战。而在抑郁方面，我认为孩子可能会开始谈论死亡或濒死的话题，或者对事情永远不会好转感到绝望。
and if you notice some of those signs, it may be important to reach out to a mental health professional. Does it help in any way for parents to try to make games out of some of what's going on? I think it's important to keep them entertained. And I'm not sure exactly how, you know, beneficiary it might be to make a game about coronavirus, specifically or COVID-19. But I think in terms of helping them navigate, you know, this stress. period, that that might be helpful. It may be part of the activity may be around identifying things around steps to sort of keep yourself safe and that might be helpful as a strategy to increase safety planning.
如果您注意到这些迹象，寻求心理健康专业人士的帮助可能很重要。父母尝试将正在发生的一些事情变成游戏有帮助吗？我认为让他们保持娱乐很重要。我不确定将冠状病毒或新冠肺炎专门变成游戏有多大益处。但我认为，在帮助他们度过这段压力时期方面，这可能会有帮助。活动的一部分可能围绕识别保持自身安全的步骤，这作为一种加强安全规划的策略可能会有帮助。
I guess I was thinking more about singing while you wash your hands or just any kind of a ritual that you might have around getting your masks on or something silly like that. Yes, no, no, I think that's great. I think especially for younger kids because it helps them sort of remember steps and things like that. And obviously with the hand washing, for example, you know, we've talked about this sort of length of time that is appropriate to wash your hands. And so if the song sort of fits that time frame, then that also helps, you know, get kids engaged in that activity. So I do think that that is a great way to help them to maintain some of those things to help them be safe. So I know you do a lot of work looking at multicultural families.
我想的是洗手时唱歌，或者围绕戴口罩建立某种仪式，或者类似这样的小把戏。是的，不，不，我认为这很好。我认为特别是对于年幼的孩子，因为这有助于他们记住步骤之类的事情。显然，以洗手为例，我们已经讨论过洗手的适当时长。因此，如果歌曲的长度符合那个时间框架，那么这也有助于让孩子参与到活动中。所以我确实认为这是帮助他们保持这些习惯以确保安全的好方法。我知道您做了很多关于多元文化家庭的研究。
Could you talk a little bit about how the COVID-19 pandemic is affecting them specifically? What are the challenges that they face? Yeah, I think one of the challenges is that maybe is not talked about as much in the media is about multi-generational families. And so if you have families that include grandparents, aunts, uncles, cousins, etc., that may be in the same home, that makes it much more. difficult when we think about some of the guidelines around physical distancing and things like that.
您能谈谈新冠疫情对他们有什么具体影响吗？他们面临哪些挑战？是的，我认为媒体中讨论较少的一个挑战是关于多代同堂的家庭。因此，如果家庭中包括祖父母、叔叔阿姨、堂表亲等，且住在同一个屋檐下，那么在考虑身体距离等准则时，情况会变得更加困难。
And obviously, if people may have to leave the home for work, et cetera, then those may be additional challenges because it may make it much more difficult to sort of maintain some of those things in terms of, you know, exposure that people may have been in contact with. So I think that's a definite concern that may be an issue for those families. And obviously, when we talk about older adults who may also be at a much higher risk, if you have those individuals in the home that could potentially increase some anxiety for kids for fear about, you know, their grandmother or grandfather being impacted by COVID-19. We talked a moment ago about maybe limiting some of the screen time that kids get right now,
显然，如果人们必须离家工作等，那么这些可能会带来额外的挑战，因为这使得在接触史方面保持某些准则变得更加困难。所以我认为这绝对是这些家庭需要关注的问题。显然，当我们谈论可能处于更高风险的老年人时，如果家里有这些人，可能会增加孩子对祖父母因新冠肺炎而受到影响的恐惧，从而增加焦虑感。我们刚才谈到了限制孩子目前的屏幕时间……
particularly watching the news media. And I know there's research-based advice suggesting that parents should do what they call in psychology scaffolding their children's screen used by watching TV and playing online games with them to help them understand what they're seeing on screen. Can you explain a little more about how that works? Yeah, no, I think that's really helpful. And I think, you know, one of the things about the screen time aspect of it is that there is some physical aspects to it in terms of how it could put additional strain on. the body and so that might be of a concern. And then I also think about, you know, some of the limitations around physical activity. And so for kids that may not be as active and then they're constantly in front of a screen,
特别是观看新闻媒体。我知道有基于研究的建议，认为父母应该在心理学上对孩子的屏幕使用进行“脚手架”式引导，即通过陪他们看电视和玩在线游戏，帮助他们理解屏幕上看到的内容。您能多解释一下这是如何运作的吗？是的，不，我认为这非常有帮助。我认为关于屏幕时间的一个方面是，它在身体层面可能会给身体带来额外的压力，所以这可能是一个担忧。此外，我还考虑到身体活动的局限性。对于那些不太活跃且总是面对屏幕的孩子来说……
then that might lead to some other sorts of health concerns as well. So I think using the process where you are using different types of screens and limiting access, that might be really helpful in terms of kids and making sure that they are. engaged in that they are, you know, if it's learning activities that they may be involved in, that there's a mix of those, in addition to some things that may be, you know, more enjoyable like games that they're playing as well. So if a parent decides that their child is having issues that parent him or herself can't handle, how should they go about getting help? Yeah, I mean, there are a number of ways that parents can get help right now. One, many
这可能会导致其他一些健康问题。因此，我认为使用这种过程，即您使用不同类型的屏幕并限制访问，在确保孩子参与方面非常有帮助。如果是学习活动，确保有多种形式，此外还有一些更令人愉快的活动，比如他们玩的游戏。如果父母认为孩子出现了他们自己无法处理的问题，他们应该如何寻求帮助？是的，我的意思是，父母现在有很多途径可以获得帮助。第一，许多……
organizations or psychological associations may be offering some either reduce services, reduce fee services to families, or they may be providing no-cost services to families as well. So I think one step might be to look at your state psychological association on their website to see if they are offering any services to families. If you have health insurance that covers mental health services, obviously you can reach out to your insurance provider to look into what access is available to you that's in your network. So that's another possibility. And then I think there are resources from different organizations like APA that offer some quick guides about how to manage certain strategies in terms of, anxiety and depression and some behavioral challenges as well. So I think those resources from,
组织或心理学协会可能正在为家庭提供减费服务，或者他们也可能提供免费服务。因此，我认为第一步可能是查看您所在州的心理学协会网站，看看他们是否为家庭提供任何服务。如果您有涵盖心理健康服务的健康保险，显然您可以联系您的保险提供商，了解您网络内有哪些可用的服务。这是另一种可能性。此外，我认为像美国心理学会（APA）这样的不同组织也提供了一些关于如何管理焦虑、抑郁和行为挑战的快速指南。因此，我认为来自……
you know, well-known, reputable websites might also be helpful in sort of the short term. For parents of older kids who are missing out on big milestones like graduation and prom, what are some things that parents can do to help them work their way through this? It always seems like a huge thing when you're 17. I know that, you know, that it's not in the scheme of life, but when you're 17, it is the biggest thing. Mm-hmm. Yeah, I mean, I think those milestones oftentimes set the stage for sort of major transitions in life. And so when we are in this sort of pandemic in that those milestones can be celebrated,
知名、信誉良好的网站的资源在短期内也可能有所帮助。对于那些错过了毕业典礼和舞会等重大里程碑的大孩子的父母，父母可以做些什么来帮助他们度过难关？当你17岁时，这似乎是一件大事。我知道，在人生的宏大计划中这不算什么，但当你17岁时，这就是最大的事。嗯。是的，我的意思是，这些里程碑往往为人生中的重大转变奠定了基础。因此，当我们处于这种疫情中，这些里程碑无法庆祝时……
it can definitely be devastating, you know, to teenagers specifically. And so I think, you know, trying to do what you can at home to be able to to celebrate that achievement for them is really helpful as one aspect. And then I think, you know, trying to get their perspective and opinion as well about how they would like to maybe make the best out of the situation. So what would be helpful for them, I think, is another important aspect of it so that it's not just about you as a parent and thinking, you know, what's most important for them to sort of celebrate this milestone, but how would they like to celebrate it?
这对青少年来说绝对是毁灭性的。因此，我认为在家里尽你所能去庆祝他们的成就确实是一个方面。此外，我认为尝试获取他们的观点和意见，了解他们如何最好地利用这种情况也很重要。因此，对他们来说什么是有帮助的，我认为这是另一个重要的方面，这样这就不只是关于作为父母的您认为庆祝这个里程碑最重要的是什么，而是他们想如何庆祝？
And so I think that is also a very helpful aspect of that. And then I know that I've seen on social media as well as television where some schools are doing like drive-by graduations and celebration so the teachers and the principals will get in their cars and drive through the neighborhood for the kids. And so I think that's really beneficial. you at least one way to be able to sort of promote that achievement for them. What do you think will happen when shelter-in-place orders do really end around the country? Do you think that COVID-19 is going to lead to some permanent changes in our families?
所以我认为这也是非常有帮助的一点。而且我知道我在社交媒体和电视上也看到过，一些学校正在举办类似“免下车”毕业典礼和庆祝活动，老师和校长会开车穿过社区去看望孩子们。所以我认为这非常有益。这至少是一种能够促进他们成就感的方式。您认为当全国各地的居家令真正结束时会发生什么？您认为新冠疫情会导致我们家庭发生永久性的变化吗？
I think so. I think that, you know, we've talked about this idea about, you know, is this the new normal, for example, or are things going to, you know, get back to, you know, where they were before COVID-19, and I think that it's going to change the way that we live, at least for a couple of years, if not forever, because I think that obviously, because we don't have a cure or vaccine for the virus, that we're going to have to continue to maintain some level of physical distancing for a while, even though we are not still sheltered in place. we're also going to have to make sure that we continue to do things in terms of how we engage from a school environment. I was watching something recently about, you know, school districts trying to make decisions around what school is going to look like, you know, once summer is over.
我想会的。我认为，我们讨论过关于“这是新常态”的想法，或者事情是否会回到新冠疫情之前，我认为这至少在几年内，如果不是永远的话，会改变我们的生活方式。因为显然，由于我们没有针对病毒的疗法或疫苗，即使我们不再居家隔离，我们也必须在一段时间内继续保持一定程度的身体距离。我们还必须确保在学校环境的参与方式上继续做些事情。我最近看到一些关于学区试图在暑假结束后决定学校将是什么样子的报道。
And so I think that is probably going to change for most children and that they may not maybe the class sizes may be much smaller. or maybe there's shorter days in the school week. And so that's going to impact parents. And what happens with their work days? Are they going to have enough flexibility to be able to be at home if their child's school day is cut short? So I think there are going to be a lot of challenges that we're going to have to continue to navigate and figure out. Yeah, these are really confusing times. Yes.
所以我认为这对大多数孩子来说可能会改变，班级规模可能会小得多，或者上学周的天数会缩短。这会影响父母。他们的工作日会发生什么？如果孩子的上学时间缩短，他们是否有足够的灵活性待在家里？所以我认为我们将不得不继续应对和解决许多挑战。是的，这些确实是令人困惑的时期。是的。
Some people are warning that we may experience a kind of mental health pandemic as a result of the coronavirus pandemic. And at a minimum, we should probably expect to see an increase in post-traumatic stress disorder, especially among those frontline workers and the first responders and also people have lost their jobs. How can psychology help mitigate these impacts? Yeah, I think, you know, a lot of conversations have been around psychological first date, for a couple of years. And so I think that's one way that psychology can be helpful to at least reduce the risk that may be associated with mental health challenges post. Yeah, can you explain what that means, psychological first aid?
一些人警告说，由于冠状病毒大流行，我们可能会经历一种心理健康大流行。至少，我们可能预计会看到创伤后应激障碍（PTSD）的增加，特别是在那些一线工作人员、急救人员以及失业人员中。心理学如何帮助减轻这些影响？是的，我认为过去几年里，很多对话都围绕着“心理急救”。所以我认为这是心理学可以提供帮助的一种方式，至少可以降低与心理健康挑战相关的风险。
Yes. So psychological first aid is a concept that I believe originally developed around sort of response to national disasters and what can we do to help those people cope. with those situations such as maybe hurricanes or things like that. And so when we apply that to situations such as the pandemic is really providing resources about what are some ways to one recognize signs of increased psychological distress or anxiety or depression, and then what are some strategies or tips about how to cope with those situations in the moment? And so I think sort of applying psychological first state to COVID-19 and the pandemic is that we really do need to be mindful about getting out resources to people now about what are some early warning signs of, you know, your body letting you know that something needs to happen and be different.
是的，您能解释一下“心理急救”是什么意思吗？是的。所以心理急救是一个概念，我相信它最初是围绕对自然灾害的反应而发展的，即我们能做些什么来帮助人们应对飓风等情况。因此，当我们将其应用于疫情等情况时，它实际上是提供资源，说明如何识别心理困扰、焦虑或抑郁增加的迹象，以及在当下应对这些情况的策略或技巧是什么？因此，我认为将心理急救应用于新冠疫情，我们确实需要注意现在就向人们提供资源，说明身体发出需要改变的早期预警信号是什么。
And so I think from the sort of anxiety perspective, we need to recognize that, you know, if we start to feel muscle tension, tension, if we start to feel like, you know, we're having breathing difficulties in a situation because we are stressed and worried that that may be one of the signs that, okay, you need to take a break now and, you know, take a break from, you know, having too many Zoom meetings back to back or take a break from, you know, for a child, being able to sit and maybe do some sort of academic work and then give yourself some time to sort of calm down and sort of recenter yourself. And so I think those are some strategies that might be helpful to mitigate the risk of mental health challenges post dealing with some of the restrictions around COVID-19.
因此，从焦虑的角度来看，我们需要认识到，如果我们开始感到肌肉紧张，如果我们因为压力和担忧而在某种情况下感到呼吸困难，这可能就是需要休息的信号之一。比如，从连续不断的Zoom会议中休息一下，或者对于孩子来说，在完成某种学术工作后，给自己一些时间冷静下来并重新调整自己。所以我认为这些策略可能有助于减轻在处理新冠疫情限制措施后出现心理健康挑战的风险。
Are you feeling anything hopeful or positive coming out of this whole situation? I'm going to think, you know, one of the things that has been sort of discussed recently about how COVID-19 is really changing. Everyone is that despite the challenges and difficulties that we are doing, dealing with right now that people are still being able to be fairly productive and life has been able to sort of continue on some levels. And so I think this has shown us as a society that, you know, there have been a lot of things in terms of like, you know, a typical 40-hour work week that we're not necessarily doing right now. And people are still being able to be productive.
您对整个局势有什么希望或积极的感觉吗？我想，最近讨论的一件事是新冠疫情如何真正改变了每个人。尽管我们现在正在处理挑战和困难，但人们仍然能够相当高效，生活在某些层面上得以继续。所以我认为这向我们展示了作为一个社会，我们在典型的每周40小时工作制方面有很多事情并不是必须做的。人们仍然能够保持高效。
And so I think some conversations that I saw recently on the news around some organizations may be allowing their employees to decide if they want to continue to work virtually as opposed to return to the office once the restrictions are lifted. And so I think in that sense, it has shown us that, you know, we can be resilient as individuals and as a society, despite, you know, know, the challenges associated with COVID-19. Thank you for joining us, Dr. Turner. I think those insights were very helpful. I hope our listeners appreciate your thoughts. Thank you for having me. The American Psychological Association has many resources and tipsheets available on our website
所以我认为我最近在新闻中看到的一些对话，关于一些组织可能允许员工决定在限制解除后是继续虚拟办公还是回到办公室。所以我认为从这个意义上说，它向我们展示了，尽管有与新冠疫情相关的挑战，我们作为个人和社会仍然可以具有韧性。感谢您参加我们的节目，特纳博士。我认为这些见解非常有帮助。希望我们的听众能欣赏您的想法。谢谢您的邀请。美国心理学会的网站上有许多资源和提示单。
for help in navigating the pandemic, including special resources for families and caregivers. Visit us at APA.org. You can also find previous episodes of Speaking of Psychology on our website at Speaking of Psychology.org. And you can subscribe to our podcast on Apple, Stitcher, or wherever you get your podcasts. While you're there, please give us a rating. If you have comments or ideas for future podcasts, email us at speaking of psychology at APA.org. That's speaking of psychology, all one word, at APA.org. Thank you for listening for the American Psychological Association. I'm Kim Mills. There aren't comments yet for this episode. Click on any sentence in the transcript to leave a comment.
可用于帮助应对疫情，包括为家庭和护理人员提供的特殊资源。请访问我们的网站 APA.org。您也可以在我们的网站 SpeakingofPsychology.org 上找到《心理学谈话》的往期节目。您可以在 Apple、Stitcher 或任何您获取播客的地方订阅我们的播客。在您收听时，请给我们评分。如果您对未来的播客有评论或想法，请发送电子邮件至 speakingofpsychology@apa.org。那是 speakingofpsychology，全部连在一起，@apa.org。感谢您的收听，我是美国心理学会的金·米尔斯。本集目前还没有评论。点击转录稿中的任何句子即可发表评论。